[Music]
all right so one of the things you need
to be lexicographer is something called
spraga fuel which is a word we stole
into german and it means a feeling for
language so sprocket fuel is the thing
that tells you for instance that the
sentence the cat are yelling is
grammatically wrong but the crowd are
loving it is just very British and so
sprocket fuel is a great word because
the Germans have Germans have words for
everything and one of and so we still
rock the fuel in with a bunch of other
German words that also describe these
things that it's just great to have one
word for so one word the German has that
describes this great great thing we
don't necessarily have a word for in
English the German word is comer spec
and it refers it's a word sort of her
flab like the weight that you gain but
the the words literally mean grief bacon
in German and so grease bacon is the
sadness you feel having all this flab so
core respec is one let me think
there's a danish word huge a I think
it's how you say it
hy g GE which refers to the coziness of
home we don't have that in English but
it's Giga is also this very broad
cultural phenomenon so a hand knit socks
are huge a and fireplaces are he gay oh
so another another word is it's a
Finnish word from Finland omitsu sissu
is sort of generally refers to
determination but determination doesn't
quite capture it it's a spirit of of
determination and sort of quiet sissu is
sort of like determination or the best
that I could possibly come up with piss
and vinegar but in a very quiet and
Scandinavia
for say so
[Music]